the anger the fear the division with
covid19 has come a new anti-vaccination
movement distinct from those who are
vaccine hesitant anti-vaxx propaganda is
designed to do harm
the best anti-vaxxers are really good
marketers too so look the actual
algorithms that that underpin social
media platforms
they know that conspiracy theories are
sticky which is that once you've had one
you want to know more about it because
they're new they're exciting they're
different and so they feed you more and
more and we found that in our studies we
found the actual algorithm recommending
and feeding people more and more
conspiracy theories
young people who live more of their
lives than ever before online are prime
targets for anti-vaxxers and teachers
worry the pull of the internet is too
strong to counter without help from the
government they obviously look on social
media they see quite a lot of jokes i
think on instagram tick tock there's
lots of jokes about i'll get my vaccine
and then this happens to me i think it
still has an effect on them that they
think will actually you know instead of
vaccines being something quite dull
boring and necessary it's something that
is controversial weird and slightly
alarming ministers are promising tough
new measures including fines to stop
anti-vaxx videos online but they accept
policing the internet is a difficult
task the internet is a large space and
there is definitely more to do and in
fact in the coming months we're going to
be introducing a piece of legislation
the online safety bill to go even
further in imposing statutory legal
duties on social media firms to make
sure they act in this area
labour says ministers must get tougher
legislation is a first unnecessary step
to this and it would send a clear
message to those tech companies that we
will not stand for inaction on
disinformation and misinformation
especially on something as important as
the corvid vaccine i would urge
everybody to speak to registered medical
professionals if you are hesitant about
getting the vaccine please don't listen
to somebody on social media purporting
to know the truth
social media isn't real life some people
may never see anti-vaxx material but
those who do can find themselves sucked
in without realizing and it's changing
the way we think about medicine science
and whether we trust our politicians
kate mccann sky news